in roam freely he wrote books and miles
and miles of letters to The Times of
London and the New York Times he was a
diplomat his deepest need though was to
teach and not necessarily in a classroom
he loved to go into pubs and hold great
debates and at Oxford as a Rhodes
Scholar as you've already been told his
life's thesis actually took shape during
one of these massive debates he in 1938
he published his first book did with
this was followed by seven more and he
argued from the beginning and quite
outrageous lead to many in Britain there
were there were horrible reviews of this
book that America would soon enough
take Britain's place in the world order
my uncle was not an economist he was a
combination historian and political
scientist his publisher was Macmillan in
Britain he was praised for clarity of
thought ease of writing style
willingness to expound original thought
some of the precepts of your magazine
mr. editor I think we'll be good
partners shortly before Lionel's death
in 1989 he established this book price
and the foundation which has
subsequently made partnerships with the
Munk Center at the University of Toronto
and now with foreign policy magazine
this year we gave the award to another
man who is published by Macmillan in the
UK another man whose work investigates
the sometimes brutal change in economic
and political power between those two
countries albeit in this case to the
life of one man John Maynard Keynes this
man is also not an economist but a
historian he sits as a life peer in the
House of Lords and has taught at Warrick
University since 1978 the expression
bringing one's work home takes on new
meaning with Robert Skidelsky he lives
in Keynes former home the ghosts hovered
as he completed the third and second
volumes of this great labor of love he
believes that he and my uncle would have
had much to discuss about anglo-american
relations the role of
Britain in the new post September 11th
world but it's many better for you to
listen to this extremely ready and
engage
man for himself come on Robert doesn't
thank you open Thank You Nance for that
introduction and ladies and gentlemen
it's a a great pleasure to be here and
to be talking about new alliance is an
old world war two lessons for the
coalition against terrorism and that is
my theme and the 60th anniversary of
Pearl Harbor to the day is an apt their
grim introduction to my lecture this
morning the Japanese attack on Pearl
Harbor created the grand alliance
against fascism just as the 11th of
September attack on the World Trade
Center the Pentagon brought into being
the global coalition against terrorism
the leaders of the grand alliance the
first grand alliance were the United
States Britain and Russia with China
somewhat distant fourth today's chess
board hasn't changed that much the Brits
are still there with his historical debt
to metonic Henry Kissinger has started
to talk about a new concept of great
powers to keep peace in the new century
but I want to take the parallel just a
little further before it runs out of
steam in each case it was an attack on
the United States which brought the
global coalition into existence before
1941 America was isolationist before the
11th of September it its policy was
called unilateralis each of the two
attacks forces the Americans to engage
more strenuously in a world from which
geography and history had shielded them
the
questions remain as before on what terms
with what aims with what permanence and
with what friends well in order to try
and answer some of those I want to look
back on the the first grand alliance see
how it worked
see what principles animated it I
covered only a small part of this in my
third volume on Keynes which has just
been published here my book deals with
anglo-american relations and actually
with a subset of those relations the
economic and financial relations between
the two countries
here the protagonists were not Churchill
and FDR but Keynes who virtually ran
Britain's external financial policy in
the war and the American counterparts
with whom he dealt particularly Henry
Morgenthau Harry Dexter white Dean
Acheson to some extent as well while the
two leaders war leaders concentrated on
how to fight the war Keynes and his
colleagues concentrated on how to pay
for it as Keynes rate of Churchill's
visit to FDR soon after Pearl Harbor
it's been a question of two buddies
sitting round large writing large
numbers of tanks and planes on paper
with no financial matter given a
moment's consideration what kind of
alliance was this for many Americans it
has been forever embalmed in the warm
glow of Churchill's memorable prose a
union of the two great democracies
fighting and fascism a union cemented
not just by shared values but by an
unparalleled act of generosity by the
United States in the form of lend-lease
these memories have merged almost
seamlessly into the start of Marshall
aid the creation of the NATO alliance
the war against communism and America's
ascent to world leadership now reality
and myth are related but not quite as
close as memory has made them and our
American readers might be shocked by the
revelation in my concluding volume of
the bitterness of wartime anglo-american
rivalry Churchill was fighting to
preserve the British Empire Keynes's war
aim as he put it was the retention by us
of enough assets to leave ourselves
capable of independent action my book
deals mainly with Keynes's struggle to
achieve his war aim indeed the retention
by Britain of enough assets for
independent action was a necessary
condition of Britain's survival as a
great power and what about the United
States well it was far from being in
accord with either of these objectives
it wanted the war to end certainly with
Britain and the United States victorious
but with Britain's somewhat diminished
cut down to size no longer in a position
to oppose American plans for post-war
order so under the facade of the grand
alliance and intense jockeying for
post-war our position was going on and
that shouldn't surprise people because
that is what alliance is alike and we
shouldn't forget that now in this
struggle the United States had an
immense a very strong weapon to hand and
that was lend-lease
lend-lease had a double aim the first
was to keep Britain in the war partly
for the protection of the United States
itself by keeping Hitler out of the
Atlantic remember the lend-lease bill
was enacted in March 1941 eight months
before Pearl Harbor and when it was
enacted it was by no me
certain clear when or whether the United
States would enter the war it was a
brilliant political ploy by Roosevelt to
bypass the neutrality acts which for bad
American government loans to
belligerence but in principle and this
again I'm sort of
trying to chip away at America's
self-image of uniqueness in principle it
was no different from the way Britain
had subsidized its allies in the 18th
century in the wars against France but
the American administration also
realized that lend-lease could be used
as a lever to bring pressure on Britain
to sign up to American plans for the
post-war world a world in which the
British Empire would have ceased to
exist as a significant force and it
would have ceased to exist with its
Imperial preference system and its
sterling area which discriminated
against American goods
now this is then one of the major plots
of my book Keynes's wrangles with the
Americans was so fierce that he was
driven to right I always regard a visit
to the United States in the nature of a
serious illness to be followed by
convalescence the lessons for today ah
that the politics of any wartime
alliance are concerned not just with how
to achieve victory but how to share the
sacrifices and allocate the gains of
victory now this brings me to a second
theme from the past which is also
relevant today how to make the peace
Keynes wrote memorably about this in his
famous polemic against the Treaty of
Versailles the economic consequence
the piece it was published in 1919 now a
good piece settlement is one that
results in a durable peace the Treaty of
Paris which ended the Napoleonic Wars is
an example of one such so in the earlier
so earlier was the Treaty of Westphalia
which ended the 30 Years War the 17th
century but though it might be thought
was the physical destruction of Carthage
which brought to an end the century long
cycle of Punic Wars after the last
Carthaginian defeat in 202 BC so there
are various sorts of good peace in the
limited sense I'm defining it as a
settlement that leads to a durable peace
in his economic consequences of the
peace Keynes
took the classic view that either you
crushed your enemy finally or you have
to conciliate it the worst outcome was a
peace which was too harsh to conciliate
but not harsh enough to crush very
classic very classic international
relations a foreign policy standpoint
this in essence is how Keynes viewed the
Treaty of Versailles that it was too
harsh to conciliate not harsh enough to
crush Germany and he predicted quite
accurately the Germany would seek
vengeance in particular he attacked the
policy of reparations which he saw as
maximizing the irritation of the
defeated with minimum benefits for the
victors
now in the planning in the Second World
War was for a Carthaginian peace its
most extreme expression was the
morgenthau plan for the plaster ization
of Germany as well as its breakup when
someone suggested to Morgenthau that a
past realized germany would not be able
to support its existing population he
replied well why not send them to
somewhere in Africa that was a
Carthaginian peace that was being
contemplated now in its extreme form the
morgenthau plan was never carried out
but there is little doubt that Germany
was much more harshly treated after the
Second World War than after the first
and deservedly so it's structure of a
structural basis of its power to renew
eh-eh-eh-eh-eh war or to fight a new war
was dismembered the same policy was
applied to Japan we shouldn't forget
that both countries were physically
occupied by the victors for many years
our several years after the war and
subsequently both countries were
embedded in structures controlled by the
United States and by the Soviet Union as
well Germany only really recovered some
power of independent action in high
politics after 1990 and the fall of
communism 50 years after Hitler
unleashed the European war I'll suggest
a moment that these historical
considerations are not entirely
irrelevant in considering how to make
peace after the events of the 11th of
September now America's relationship to
what might be called this brown
tradition of European diplomacy has
always been very ambivalent George
Washington's remark there can be no
greater error than to expect or
calculate upon real favors from nation
to nation was a clarion call to
isolationism which echoed down American
history Washington understood the basic
law of international relations which is
why he wanted to make America wanted
America to steer clear of entangling
alliances because they would Sully
America's original virtue
now of course isolation isolationist was
long ceased to be an option for album
the most powerful nation in the world
but the isolationist legacy is still
there it helps explain not just the
somewhat intermittent attention the
United States gives to foreign policy
but the feeling that when they are
engaged in foreign policy it is from a
position of unique virtue here I'm going
to say some things which perhaps may be
a little hurtful but they're not as our
sentiment it not really meant to be
Americans think think naturally in terms
of alliances and alliance politics they
want to be I'll uninvolved or masters of
the situation for example the European
notion of the balance of power has never
had much resonance in the United States
and despite the heroic efforts of my
friend David Kaleo who has been arguing
this case for many years Americans like
to think of their own country as
uniquely godly in a world of fallen
angels they like to think that their
plans are gen genuinely good for
everyone and are shocked and startled
when others disagree with this President
Woodrow Wilson came to the Paris Peace
Conference trailing what Georges
Clemenceau
the French Prime Minister called his 14
commandments and the Roosevelt
administration too had extensive plans
for the post-war world war world built
on American principles wafted from
isolationism to world supremacy the
United States has never comfortably
occupied the intermediate ground of
international relations where everything
is a little grayer or a little less gray
Americans want partners or supporting
pillars but not allies because they
believe that they have the best script
now I'm very far from trying to douse
this new world
idealism with old-world cynicism that's
not my intention the power to do good is
extremely seductive and not always
illusory an Atlantic community which in
some ways might be thought of as an
extension of the United States United by
the shared value of freedom resolute in
its defense gradually extending its
boundaries to embrace more and more
countries is a noble vision it's a
vision with a strong appeal to the
British whose own 19th century imperial
idea was rooted in the principle Roman
principle if you like of universal
citizenship how a much practice diverged
from preset moreover I mean this is a
point I want to emphasize we might for
the first time in history be in a
position where there is today a genuine
world power one that cannot be
effectively challenged by any other
combination of parts that is the United
States this it could be argued makes
possible a quantum leap in international
organization from the old politics of
competitive imperialism and the balance
of power to a new prosperous humane
world order one based on certain
principles which
be enforced universally the
judeo-christian tradition the rule of
law the supremacy of Liberty the spirit
of scientific inquiry these values of
the West we're almost in a position to
feel that they can be universalized for
the first time because there's a power
of sufficient world stature to be in a
position to do it more powerful than the
British Empire ever was and so are we
not for the first time in a position to
overcome the limitations of national
imperial rivalries which has kept the
world poor and warlike and savage and so
on for so long
a tantalizing prospect I wonder how many
in the United States administration
sherry but in the nature of things I
doubt whether it can be realized in
quite that form more of any attempt to
realize it will I suggest stir up such
enmities and hatreds eventually backed
by countervailing power that the wars of
the 20th century will come to see like
minor incidents so while the United
States has to be the paramount leader in
international affairs the new world
order has also to be negotiated let me
come back to the grand alliance which
won the second world war today
it's commonly believed that at its core
was the anglo-american special
relationship yet if one goes through the
history as I've done as the main thing
special about the relationship was its
difficulties these difficulties only
waned gradually and only waned a when
British power waned actually and and the
Soviet threat became apparent to my mind
there's been a systematic miss reading
of Anglo
in relations and a projection backwards
through in time of a partnership which
was only really fully consummated after
the Second World War I know this is a
kind of heresy but that's what my
reading of the evidence leads me to the
root idea has been in this conventional
view that there's a natural partnership
of what church shall call the
english-speaking peoples Churchill was
one of the great propagators of an ideal
which he took to be already realized but
actually what he wanted was to bring it
about that partnership of the
english-speaking peoples which disclosed
itself in two world wars and then and
then and then the story goes on in a
familiar way about the Americans taking
over from the Brits and and the
conventional view opens with the Anglo
American a rapprochement of 1898 to 1906
in which number of vexations disputes
ranging from alaska to venezuela was
settled largely in on america's terms
and in the course of which Britain took
the view to exclude the possibility of
war with the United States and the
future in order to be able better to
meet pressing challenges elsewhere now
that's quite right but it leaves out
that Britain was simultaneously seeking
to insure itself against potentially
fatal combinations or enemies by making
alliances with Germany and Japan and
that policy was also pursued in tandem
and the alliance with Japan came off the
alliance with Germany didn't much more
important the conventional view of the
seamless web of the rise of
anglo-american partnership leaves out
the fact that the first world war was
followed by a wave of isolationism
driven very largely by Anglophone BIA
American public discourse in the
interwar years was dominated by the
views of the
should inveigle the United States into a
war which served not the interests of
the American people but of a small group
of finances and arms manufacturers and
that led directly to the neutrality acts
the roots of American Anglophilia lay in
the war of independence itself but it
was nourished by the Irish and German
migrations by the existence of the
British Empire particularly the indian
empire by financial and commercial
competition all over the world by the
suspicion of the british ruling class
was pro-fascist by deep cultural
insecurities and so on Anglophone is
stretched across the political parties
it tended to make the Republicans
isolationist despite some east coast
Anglophilia the Democrats were more
interventionist in in the early 1940s
but from Roosevelt onwards there was the
conviction that while the United States
might need to go to war to rid the world
of Nazism it should not do so to defend
Britain's world position as late as the
9th of October 1945 after the Second
World War was over a British Treasury
official in Washington rate the
pro-british line always needs defending
in this country the anti British line
never that was after the special
relationship had supposedly been
established
let me draw attention to one neglected
neglected piece of history the financial
and commercial rivalry between the two
nations
now Britain may have been the going
concern and the United States the coming
concern as Harry Dexter white put it
with his customary brutal frankness but
Britain had a lot of assets left to keep
it going and among these assets chief of
them was the British Empire itself which
in 1932 started to be distorted to
discriminate against American goods a
chordal hull the USA roof
describe the Ottawa agreement of 1932 as
the greatest injury to the United States
in a commercial sense ever inflicted on
it there was nothing inevitable about
anglo-american partnership in the 1930s
indeed it was only the impossible
character of the Hitler regime which
prevented an Anglo franco-german
understanding which would have led to
substantial consolidation of European
power in the world in other words the
idea of a European Union European unity
goes back long before the present
structure came into existence it was a
gleam in the mind of many people and its
object was precisely to create a
counterweight to the United States and
it was only owing to the Second World
War that in fact the European Union grew
up as an American Protectorate when
Keynes and the British ambassador Lord
Halifax first came to Washington in 1941
as begging plenipotentiaries of plucky
Britain they were soon made aware of the
true state our feeling Halifax was
regularly shouted down as he went round
the United States trying to rally
support for the British cause it was not
to August 1941 when he faced down an egg
throwing crowd in Detroit with the
unflappable remark you are lucky to have
eggs to throw
that his relations with the Americans
started to improve Keynes didn't
encounter outright hostility in
Washington so much as deep suspicions of
British motives which his reputation for
cleverness did nothing to dispel when he
first arrived at the US Treasury one of
Morgan Tours officials asked his private
secretary where's your lawyer when the
British official explained they hadn't
brought any he got the reply will who
does your thinking for you came as of
course was perfectly capable of doing
his own thinking but the very speed of
his thinking and the subtle quality of
his plans inflamed the suspicion that he
was trying to pull a fast one as indeed
he was he's one of those fellows that
just knows all the answers you see Harry
Hopkins tell Morgan tore the telephone
the Americans knew that the British were
in a hole at one point in the second
Quebec conference in 1944 Churchill said
to Roosevelt what do you want me to do
stand out stand up and beg you like
Fowler the president's dog this was not
Churchill style and it wasn't Keynes's
as a British Treasury official stationed
in Washington perceptibly wrote may not
that's Keynes thinks were great and
independent nation which on the
financial side patently isn't true I
think he's inclined to ask as a right
what they're prepared to give us as a
favor the British fought hard to retain
some maneuvering power in the grand
alliance short of the unthinkable
sanction of making a separate peace with
Nazi Germany
Churchill refused to discuss the future
of the British Empire with Roosevelt
when forced to he agreed to pass
declarations like the Atlantic Charter
in financial and economic negotiations
the British inserted or tried to insert
escape clauses
into every commitment they signed up to
on the whole it was a losing battle on
his last financial mission to Washington
in in in 1945 gangs raged his mother
made never fall to my lot again to have
to persuade anyone to do what I want
with so few cards in my hands the fact
that the post war war war world order it
turned out to be somewhat worse than the
Americans had hoped but somewhat better
than the British feared it would be was
the achievement not of the Americans or
the British but of the third pillar in
that grand alliance the Soviet Union
here I come to a little more
controversial point and my last point
really before I try and sum this up many
members of the Roosevelt administration
including I think Roosevelt himself
expected the Soviet Union and not Great
Britain to be the United States his
chief post-war partner now this was
seems incredible but I think the
evidence is very strong it was partly a
matter of power liking to talk to power
and Russians had power the Americans had
power British well they had a bit of
power but not nearly as much and that
was the first point
secondly they weren't rivals they hadn't
been squabbling for the last 20 30 40
years they were who is to be the
financial center of the world who is to
control the world's commerce there was
nothing to quarrel about that was
ideology but here you come to the third
point there was a huge amount of
ideological allusion by this time about
the Soviet Union others it now seems the
Democratic Socialist peace-loving Soviet
Union of Uncle Joe seemed a much more
attractive partner to the American Left
than imperialist semi fascist
because Churchill was always depicted as
being Britain in fact hardly anyone in
Washington knew anything about Russia
except for its heroic resistance to
Nazism and most of the information
filtering through was largely the work
of Soviet spies Communists and fellow
travelers in FDR's administration
Britain and its empire was not only not
part of this heady vision of American
sub it company iminium but a positive
obstacle now disillusion with the
Soviets only rarely came from from 1945
to 47 final dissolution it had started
with Truman's accession to the
presidency but it came in those years
when it arrived it came like a
thunderclap and it served to validate
one of Keynes's premature remarks which
turned out to be very prescient at the
end of 1944 he Keynes comforted himself
with the thought that the United States
was committed to the restoration of
Britain as a great power American
illusions about its allies other allies
were fading there is nothing to be found
reliable or homely in the habitable
globe outside Britain and the British
Commonwealth Keynes writes this today is
America's deepest least alterable
collection a sure rock on which whatever
may appear on the surface we can build
with safety that became true it wasn't
true when he wrote it
now what lessons can we draw from today
for today well history isn't a good
basis for prediction because every
historical event is unique and despite
all out you know and and so we can't
generalize from the past and yet despite
all our backslidings we do make some
progress in understanding
world and dealing with its problems and
history can sort of actually be part of
that better understanding of the limits
and possibilities of successful action
the first lesson I would draw from the
tale I've just told is that in thinking
about foreign policy we need to
distinguish between partners and allies
of the four countries which made up the
grand alliance to defeat fascism the
United States Britain the Soviet Union
and China two became partners and the
other two ceased to be allies allies are
for the temporary objectives partners
are for the long war wars between
partners are unthinkable future wars
between allies always remain possible
America needs to think about who its
partners are today and who its allies
are there lots of allies temporary
allies in this coalition one must always
be worried about building them up too -
too high unless one is sure that they're
going to stay stay allies that is become
partners what converts allies into
partners and that's an interesting
question
shared values past associations
historical memories are all obviously
important but they're not enough
I'm skeptical for example of the idea
that democracy is never go to war all
that's necessary for a peaceful and
prosperous world to come about is that
all countries should become democratic
and I think that was the mistake made by
Francis Fukuyama in in in in his end of
history thesis which is extremely
fertile and suggestive but I think too
optimistic on that on that score um just
as important as shared values in
converting allies into partners is
asymmetry of power Britain didn't really
become a reliable partner of the United
States it was no longer powerful enough
to be a serious rival to adapt Harry
Dexter free Harry Dexter white sprays
the growing powers have to be gone
before they become part
in a joint enterprise the relationship
between the United States and Western
Europe have reached this point by the
end of the Second World War the
partnership was consolidated in the NATO
treaty during the Cold War and is now
unbreakable post-war talk of setting up
Europe as a third force between American
capitalism and Soviet Communism was
never realistic except it may be in some
aspects of social policy the historical
moment had already past partners though
need to be treated with consideration
they must believe that they have some
influence over the partnership otherwise
the full value of the partnership is
lost partners can always be also very
useful as intermediaries and go-betweens
this was the role played by Margaret
Thatcher in the Reagan Gorbachev era and
it's Blair has been playing the same
kind of hand
today in the Middle East in any
partnership there will always be an
awkward member and that role has been
played with great elegance by France -
the frequent irritation of the United
States but of some benefit to the
partnership as a whole by making it
appear to others as not wholly
subservient to American wishes Russia
and China were allies in the ground
alliance and allied with the United
States and the coalition against
terrorism today there are they partners
now although Russia I think would like
to be I'm very Pro Russian but Russia is
still very different from the west and
is right to think of itself as a coming
and not as a going power both of these
things are even more obviously true of
China now there's no reason to
anticipate that either country will be
become actively hostile to the United
States but they are in or will soon be
in a position to bargain their place in
the international
system and therefore to have a role in
shaping its future and the same will be
true of India so it in its relation to
these powers the United States will be
much more in that intermediate area of
international relations where concepts
like the balance of power are not
entirely irrelevant now what about the
Islamic world which has less of a
permanent interest in working with the
United States than Russia or China do
and which have many serious grievances
against it not least in connection with
Palestine on the one hand the facts of
power are overwhelmingly in favor of the
coalition against terrorism or even its
core the United States and its partners
and this destroys any notion that Islam
might be in a position to mount a
serious challenge to the West the
asymmetry of power is simply too great
even if the West is decadent as Islamic
fundamentalists claim unlike the
decadent civilizations of the past it
has hugely superior firepower much more
so than between the 7th and 17th century
when Islam was a serious challenger to
Christianity and the outcome of that
struggle wasn't really finally settled
until 1683 the ease and speed with which
the United States destroyed the Taliban
in Afghanistan is a much more convincing
demonstration of power than was bin
Laden's suicide mission of the 11th of
September on the other side of the coin
there unsettled Islamic grievances can
keep terrorism in business the events of
11th of September have brought clarity
to the definition of the Middle East and
problem everyone agrees things can't be
allowed to drift on as they have been
for many years in face of the
Palestinian Intifada
well what then do we do if we examine
the conflict in the light of the key
concepts we have been talking about how
about how to make a good piece there are
two alternatives the Carthaginian
solution or the conciliation now
it surely is clear to me that a
Carthaginian solution to the Palestine
question is a non-starter even if it
falls far short of the physical
liquidation of Palestinians and instead
takes the form of a permanent brutal
occupation of the occupied territories
and by Israeli American forces it this
is just not just contrary to the ethics
of the 21st century but would really
lead to a clash of civilizations and
every Islamic state would be host to
terrorists if that sort of development
happened but they couldn't overthrow the
West even so but they could inflict huge
damage on its way of life nor can the
United States and its allies restore
vanished imperialism's
all over the Islamic world too costly
and populations wouldn't support it so
we're left with conciliation or to use a
more appropriate term appeasement as
Tony Blair said the war against
terrorism needs to remove the conditions
under which such acts of evil can
flourish the dragon's teeth are firmly
planted in the fertile soils of wrongs
unrated I don't want to say very much
more about you know I'm not going to
produce my own Middle East and peace
plan but I just want to say appeasement
has been undeservedly discredited as a
tool of statesmanship by the past
contexts of the word and the anything
wrong with appeasement is to try and
appease people who are unappeasable and
so I believe the comparison with Hitler
is unhelpful Hitler was in prince
on appeasable but I didn't think most
Islamic states are unappeasable so
that's why I hate the United States will
not now rise aisle from the efforts to
achieve the peace on on a basis just
enunciated by your Secretary of State
the argument I've been making is
admittedly state centered to use the
international relations jargon it's been
much argued that globalization is
putting the nation state out of business
that the new units of decision-making
are regional or supranational bodies
well 11th of September has shown that
what however true this may be of soft
politics it's not true of hard politics
that crucial decisions to act in the
wake of the 11th of September were taken
by Bush Blair and Putin just as in the
Second World War they had been by Reza
belt Churchill and Stalin heads of their
national governments and there are no
governments other the national
governments in the world today levels of
September showed the European Union as a
concept to be totally non operational in
this area of international relations and
it has to travel a long long way before
it can start making life-and-death
decisions on behalf of them then to sum
up the chief differences between now and
then is the power has become much more
asymmetrical this allows alliances to
become partnerships and gives the United
States much more scope to fashion a
world in its own liking but there are
limits over much of the world the older
principles of the balance of power and
the old tradition of redressing
grievances when Carthaginian pieces are
not possible
a whole sway and uh still the best guide
to foreign policy if the United States
fails to distinguish between partners
and allies treats potential allies as
enemies its foreign policy will come
adrift and the chances of achieving a
better future will be fretted away
thank you thank you this was a marvelous
lecture Lord Skidelsky will take a
couple of questions and those of you
interested in reading his wonderful
lecture can find it in our web page www
foreign-policy don't make any any
comment I'm very happy to learn there
are lots of people with hands that what
sort of order surely why don't you do it
well in first we you need to speak in
the microphone over there I was struck
by your characterization of the absolute
binary options appeasement solution or
the Carthaginian solution how does one
approach the conciliatory solution if
one of the people on the other side or
significant parties on the other side
are bent on the Carthaginian solution I
would have thought that would be the
critical question in the circumstance
certainly the varrock offer to the
Palestinians was an attempted
appeasement whether it was adequate or
not one conveyed but there's a
significant group on the other side and
specifically Hamas Islamic Jihad who are
bent on a Carthaginian solution to this
problem similarly I would think that
American relations with Islam in general
have moved for the conciliatory a
solution a significant group well
perhaps not so significant week what
that remains to be tested but certainly
al-qaeda are bent on a Carthaginians so
how do you play this game when the the
game set of the two parties in is
entirely different well I would any I
would agree with you roughly what you
said I would any add to that that there
are some cough guineans around in Israel
as well in the sense that they also want
to occupy occupy the territories
permanently so what do you do when you
have two sets of Carthaginians using
this these these the this image and and
and and some some you have to decide I
mean I am not I'm not so an optimist
about about about about situation at all
I think perhaps neither is a Colin
Powell a perhaps neither are are the
people who put forward the the present
peace plans I think what you have to
have in this situation is what Graham
she called pessimism of the intellect
and optimism of the will you know you've
got to go on and whether you succeed or
not but I put the choice in those terms
because I don't want I'm hoping that
people won't have too many illusions
about what can be a tree you know there
was a lot of talk about windows of
opportunity opening up on the 11th of
September everyone from wow this is a
chance settle all the affairs of the
world once and for all we've got these
great opportunities a coalition everyone
agrees with everything no no no no your
comment about the European Union being
our Protectorate did I understand you
right did I hear you right you did bully
for us
I'm I'm taking I'm taking a purely
classical view it's been defended mainly
by the United States it's security has
been guaranteed by the United States
that is the definition of a protectorate
it has no inherent powers it never did
of self-protection against the main
enemy which was the which was the Soviet
Union not only no inherent powers of
protection but the disparity was so huge
so I think the United States up a United
States Army and military forces in
Europe I'm not using the word in a bad
sentence
I'm not against protectorates what do
you see as the differences or the
similarities between the political
forces which drove the creation of the
Bretton Woods architecture and what is
happening now with global economic
integration well I didn't deal with that
in my a my my talk I could have done
there is a there there there is a
movement for reform of the international
architecture but I think there two
differences first of all the power to
act in this area isn't as concentrated
as it was I talked about the asymmetry
of power having grown but in this
particular case this isn't true and
we're talking now not of the top level
of politics but of a lower level the
economic and social and here power has
become more dispersed than it was in
1944 in 1944 basically Britain and
America had to agree and the deal was
done no one else mattered at all now of
course a lot of other people do matter
so the there's a reform and there are
reforms
Sal and Meltzer has a plan and and many
others do but we don't we don't have
agreement the second second thing is
that we we don't really agree on what
the reforms what what the new
architecture should be like take one
question do we want to the world of
floating exchange rates or fixed
exchange rates do we want an IMF that is
lender the last resort or not who's
going to pay for it how much how bigger
its resources going to be what should be
the terms of its intervention in the
affairs of the other countries should it
be more of a policeman or should it
intervene post-hoc you know a lot of
those issues are being discussed and
there's no consensus so they will have
to be reformed but it's not imminent and
it will be difficult thank you very much
with this we bring to a close these a
wonderful session please join me in
thanking lost
and on behalf of the Mount Center for
Galesburg foundation and foreign policy
magazine thanks for being here and we
hope to see you next year when we'll be
awarding the 2002
galbart word for the best book in the
world thank you very much